that isn't uncommon
that isn't a fantasy
because it happens
it happens
pretty much every day
do you think when a writer reaches a
certain level they no longer need to
work on craft no
[Laughter]
no that you got to remain teachable
as a writer
it's
i think it's extraordinarily important
um
[Music]
you know you always have to be willing
to learn and i think
that um
writers
tend to
give off this error that they're like
poor man intellectuals
i don't i i don't think they really are
i i think that they
um i think that they
they have to continually
um be a process in which they are
allowing themselves to be vulnerable and
open to
to new things
i think they do a good act
at um
at seeming to
be having um
[Music]
a wide array of knowledge um there's the
writers actually do talk about this um
there's a lecture um that incidentally
tony gilroy um gives where he basically
talks about
um how
how writers have this amazing capacity
to know a little bit about
um so many various subject matters but
nothing never an extensive amount about
one thing
you know we are i think in a sense
you know dilutants by by nature
you know in other words
yes we we have to be open
you know we can't
you know there's there's no
so you gotta you always gotta be
practicing you always have to be
honing your work
you're always willing to learn from
somebody else
um
there's i learned so much from from
other writers
i love to listen to
to other writers talk about how they do
things and um
and and certain techniques and ideas
that they imply
apply
um i think
any true writer is um is a curiosity
junkie
um
that they're it's just
it's just that they're
they're you just need to keep getting
more
information
you know about whatever you know
whatever is how's this work or how does
that you know that's interesting you
know um
you know even if it just flies in one
ear and then out the other later you
know we are curiosity junkies
so
that's fascinating what is a poor man or
poor woman's intellectual what is that
i like that
i might i might come under that game
what i mean by that is is like
is
is that i think that
writers do
a good job of sounding good
um
of um
sounding like they know what they're
talking about
um
i think um
there is a
there's a kind of um
sometimes the kind of
intellectual arrogance
some writers can have
um
but i don't think by nature
being a writer
is a um
is a
is a prerequisite or
or any any kind of standard for your
intellectual capacity whatsoever
um i i
i you know just because you you have a
large vocabulary doesn't make you a
professor
um
and um often i do believe others get
that confused including the writers
themselves
[Laughter]
so we believe our own hype oh yeah
jack of all trades
there you go there you go you just
explained it in such and in in terms
that are far more simpler than i just
did hence hence
hence you know um
you know explaining what i was you know
there you have it well i'm further down
on the scale i haven't i haven't
mastered total total intellectual but
what i'm curious is of um how can we
tell if we're not teachable
you talked about become being teachable
and that's something that we never stop
you know getting to that point where
you've never mastered the craft but how
do we know how can we check ourselves
that's easy
you just gotta listen
that's it
that's it you know if you aren't if you
aren't spending enough time listening
it's pretty easy
you know
that's that that's how i think that
basically you have to check yourself if
you're if you're teachable you gotta
listen to people
um you you you have to um
you have to listen to what others are
doing
um
if it jibes with you
that's cool if it doesn't that's fine
you can
you can go and do your own thing but it
doesn't mean that you um you need to
block it out
or you have to discount it because
obviously it works for them
and you don't have to hold any judgment
over it either
you think there are times when we become
unteachable and then we kind of
vastly back to being teachable and and
it's like this battle
i think that um i think that that's a
larger life question
and that
that
that um
that comes with
a bit of wisdom as a writer
um
if you're if you're a young writer you
may and you you achieve a modicum of
success you may start to believe that
you are
you're beyond any kind of
growth
that you can't develop any further and
at your craft
and then you
you might
turn around and go no i was absolutely
wrong you know it's like
you know i i do have more to learn
so i don't think that um
i i don't think that that's just a
straight
um writer
inquiry i think that's a larger
it's a larger question it goes towards
life
and one last life question and that is
do you think having early success is a
curse
these are deep philosophical areas
you're getting into
um that's my own believing my own hype
[Laughter]
but i am curious
i don't know
because i wouldn't i wouldn't know the
experience of
i think that maybe i've heard
some
writers
suggest that they
feel that they were
stifled
because they received early success
um
i
have
experience
i'm with writers and i've known writers
and
in in intimate ways that
i know that they've had issues
with success
um
because it's um
it's a very um
it's it's a seismic thing to
occur and
[Music]
often
you might get confused and
attribute it
to
to something that is
beyond
beyond even your um
even the product that you that you put
out there
um and if you do that then
you you can you can lose your way you
know and
you know at the thing that you love to
do the most if that is writing
um then you could maybe
um
you know
lose them lose a little time you know
um
writing the kind of things that you want
to write and
and developing the kind of projects you
want to work on
but um yeah yeah
i've heard of such a thing
yeah it reminds me of one of
one of the scenes i love in the movie um
end of the tour i believe about david
foster wallace and the rolling stone
journalist that comes to his house in
illinois and interviews him for a week
no i've never seen that oh it's so good
and i know it got a lot of criticism i
loved it i know there were people that
had their criticisms of it but that the
david foster wallace character says i
cherish my regular guidance
that's something i really cherish and i
am just assuming that he meant sort of
like not believing the hype you know he
was young writers 24 i believe when
infinite just came out
and and just
making sure that he cherished that
regular part of himself again i'm i'm
projecting on to that but i'm i'm i just
love that scene because you know here's
this young
journalist played by jesse eisenberg
that's coming to interview them and pick
them apart and find out what makes them
sick
and just you know the two bondis friends
and it's anyway
it's reminding me of that when you
talked about that
i have to see that now yeah i loved it
there's a lot of sad parts to it um but
it's based on a real interview that a
journalist did with him
keeping with this subject the writer who
lands success with the first screenplay
is a fantasy
why do we still think this is different
for us individually
what do you mean well so many people
think it's going to be different for me
oh yeah i'm going to i'm going to this
is different i know other people took
them 15 years to get this one film made
but they haven't seen my work yet
yeah it's
i don't know it's it's really weird um
it's um
it's it's
it's a funny thing um
when people approach it that way
to this day i find it
i find it
not only cautionary but
i kind of find it tragic
that a lot of people
come to hollywood or just in general
[Music]
come here with this hope this
this
this dream that they can they can do
this one thing
and i think that the trend has been for
the last
30 years about
then
you can write this knockout one-time
screenplay get it to the right person
and somehow
magically
you will become a star screenwriter
i think that
a part of that
has to do with
the um
the
the celebrity that has been attached to
to the screenwriting profession
recently
um well when i say recently i mean their
last 30 years
it
it wasn't like that always
it was a it was a very behind the scenes
profession and
and now it has a
a
um
it has this uh
this this heightened patina of notoriety
that people um aspire to
um it's like
you know people wanted to come to to to
or go go to go to um hollywood in the
60s so they could become
you know lead guitarist for some band
you know it's the same it's the same um
elusive objective
you know this is so gruesome but you
just triggered this memory of when i
first came to la
one of the first things i saw was a girl
that had jumped from her balcony
and we did we may cut this but her body
was covered and the neighbors were all
watching this was in hollywood and it
was like a four-story balcony and i
never forgot
that image because i always wondered who
was she why did she jump
what i mean she was living in this nice
apartment much nicer than the place i
lived in but what would prompt her
and and i guess just a reminder of that
and being so young coming here and
seeing like this
you can fall i guess is the analogy yeah
you know i'm going on a gruesome take
here but it never left me you know and
[Music]
no no i uh
yeah who wha wha what was her background
i mean like
it's like um
my my circumstances um here are um
are well they're they're actually quite
convenient um i'm from
i'm from los angeles
um i had no
ever desire to um
to get into writing or writing
screenplays
it just was something that i was
compelled to do
um
i think and it and furthermore i wasn't
compelled necessarily just to write
screenplays i started out writing poetry
and i just wanted to write
you know i think that that's pretty much
the healthiest
mode in which anyone starts writing
anything you know they're writers
um they um
they wanna write
and then it then when they they identify
oh i wanna i wanna i wanna
do a screenplay i want to write a
screenplay and it's like oh great go
ahead write a screenplay you know
um i do
i don't think your first screenplay will
is likely to probably get you
anywhere
but
if you keep writing screenplays you will
learn
and
and once you start to learn
um you will
you will hit a screenplay that'll you
know will turn some heads you know
it's that's that isn't uncommon
that isn't a fantasy
because it happens
it happens
pretty much every day
that is not a fantasy what is a fantasy
is if you come out here with one
screenplay
and you're gonna knock it out the part
and you think that that's all you need
to do because that ain't happening
you